I was shot six years ago at San
Francisco pride during the parade I was
shot in Los Angeles I didn't understand
or comprehend what had happened or why
[Music]
started hearing some yelling kind of
fighting behind me so I looked and there
was about eight guys there and I saw one
of them pull out a gun and I jumped over
a barricade to try and hide and I got
shot in midair as I was trying to hide I
was a driver for a company I was stopped
at a red light
all of a sudden shots rang off a couple
of shots into it my rear window shatters
and that's what I ended up getting shot
I was actually throwing a party that
night I was standing right by the front
steps of the house there was a really
really loud noise I didn't fall or
blackout or anything but I was turned
around when I opened my eyes and I
opened my mouth and I had Invisalign the
visit line fell out of my hand and my
teeth I looked down in my jeans that I
was wearing literally had ripped off me
from how swollen my leg of gotten this
seams her rip there was blood spewing
out and I I thought immediately I was I
was in a cartoon I just was thinking
some sick joke it happened but it was
very very real honestly I wanted to
drive home at the time I had my oldest
was seven months old and I was like I
can't die here my jaw was almost
unhinged it was down to about two inches
lower than it should be I guess and I
couldn't see the bullet hole all I could
see where that my teeth were missing and
there was just a lot of blood coming out
of my mouth the bullet itself exploded
in my leg so half the bullet came out in
half it was lodged inside right next to
my femoral artery it felt like a you
know shards of glass were going all
throughout my leg I didn't know this at
the time but I ended up getting hit
three times and my lower back it was
like this intense heat like somebody
puts you in a pot and just start boiling
used as hot after that I just lost
consciousness
I felt impact when when the bully
actually entered and that's what turned
me around I didn't feel any actual pain
until after the drugs wore off and the
shock wore off but it was more shocking
than anything they actually woke up in a
surgery table when they were inserting a
chest tube that is like the most pain
I've ever felt in my life and I just
graphed the surgeon and I said you can't
let me die I can't die here I can't die
the drugs started wearing off and I
experienced the first like pain it was
just like a really really like sharp
burning paint and right on the bottom of
my face and it just felt like it was on
fire
it just it hurt so bad and they said
well yeah you've been shot in the face I
was in the hospital just for two or
three days and I got discharged to a
hotel close by I had a really extensive
surgery and reconstructive surgery I had
stitches all the way up and down my
right leg I couldn't actually walk for
at least six months my parents had to
take care of me and bathe me and feed me
four is like going back to being a baby
my chin was shattered and my mandible
was broken so they had to remove the
debris the teeth the bone from the
bottom of my mouth and they put a plate
in my jaw to hold the mandible together
I didn't really leave my house too often
after that once I left the hospital that
I was just wasn't who I was before now
it's just every day I wake up I thank
God and I could see I can walk and you
know just kind of have that attitude no
emotional after fact or aftermath of it
was it was really hard I still struggle
with it today actually crowds always set
a trigger for me they're huge trigger I
get anxiety panic attacks I constantly
I'm scanning the room that I'm in if I
meet somebody I look at the pockets
what's in their hand it's really
exhausting but I feel like it puts me in
a safer place overall physically
it's very expensive to replace teeth and
I'm working on that now still so many
years later emotionally I feel I mean
I'm at peace with it it's something that
happened and I had to deal with so I
don't know who shot me
they did not get caught and it really
pains me to know that he's still out
there somewhere
but I saw his face I know he looks like
I've had a lot of nightmares with his
face in it if I saw him again
I actually think about this a lot I
would let him know that I forgive him
because obviously he grew up in some way
that made him angry like that so and I
forgive him nobody was ever caught I
kind of looked at it as a I was it's
kind of cliche but I was just at the
wrong place at the wrong time
I don't even spend a minute thinking
about the shooter it's just not my
concern from what I heard it was two
younger kids it didn't sound like
anything was really done to provoke them
to have done that and you don't know if
you killed someone and that's got to
make you crazy I hope it was enough to
scare them straight and they did
something better with their life you
know it really brings back memories all
the time seeing all these issues and
watching the news and seeing these
shootings that just really really is
painful to watch anyone has gone through
this sort of situation in pain just know
that you're not alone so many people
have stories to tell about being shot
honestly something has to be done
because it's not okay for people to be
scared to leave their house to go to
school and that's not the way anybody
should have to live
[Music]